hello everyone i'm jacob and i'll be
talking about noisy bullion matching
this is joint work with michael caprilov
emilia mussibatla david woodruff and
samson zhao
so first of all what is bullying in a
matching
it is a one-way communication problem
that was first introduced in 2006 and
it is the following
so the problem is between alice and bob
both have access to set of n vertices
and alice is given
vertex labels in zero one so each vertex
is labeled either with zero or one
now bob is given a large matching on
these vertices uh so typically the
matching is of linear size in the number
of vertices sometimes it can even be a
perfect matching
and the matching edges that bob gets are
all labeled with parity labels
so in the yes case which is pictured
here
the parity labels correspond to true
parities of the edges so for an edge the
parity is just the sum
of the vertex labels of its endpoints
and this is called the s case
now in the no case the labels that bob
gets are exactly the opposite of this so
they are exactly
the parity labels flipped
and the bob's job is to distinguish
between yes and no cases
and
alice gets to send a message of some
bounded size to bob to aid him in this
so this was originally studied
to show an exponential separation
between
quantum and classical communication
complexity
and
the original papers showed that
one requires at least
root n bits of communication to solve
this uh problem with with the high
constant probability
but
in later years it was found that this
was actually very useful in improving
lower bounds
for one pass
streaming problems for various graph
optimization algorithms
so here is a non-exhaustive list of
many recent results that have utilized
the bullying in matching to prove lower
bounds for graph streaming problems so
triangle counting maximum matching
maximum cut and maximum a cyclic graph
just to name a few
and
so this has been tremendously useful and
one of the
main shortcomings of google hidden
matching is that
obviously the best lower bound that you
can prove for these problems is root and
space
because uh matching itself has
communication complexity omega root time
and so in order to
strengthen the results
verbatinu in 2011
introduced boolean hidden hyper matching
which is a slight modification and
generalization of bullying matching so
it's essentially the same thing but bob
instead of getting a large matching
on the set of vertices he gets a large
hyper matching so hyper matching is
just a set of hyperedges
that are disjoint and each hyperedge
contains t vertices
and again in the s case bob receives the
correct parrot labels on each
hyperedge so that is the true sum of the
vertices labels on the average and in no
case he gets exactly the opposite
and
verb in the news showed that
you can get a much higher lower bound on
a communication capacity here the
communication context is actually omega
n to the one minus one over t
and so this also contributed to a lot of
um
graph streaming lower bounds in uh
in settings where one could get a higher
than root and lower bound for a
particular problem
and actually let's take a look at one of
these lower bounds so this is going to
be the maximum cut lower bound of
capital of khan and sudan from 2015
which utilizes booming hidden hyper
matching
so in order to turn a communication
complexity problem into a
graph streaming space lower bound
um we do a reduction from the graph
problem to the communication problem so
suppose alice and bob have an instance
of putting in hyper matching
and they can encode this into an
instance of approximate maximum cut
um
and then if an algorithm existed
efficiently and in low space solves
maximum cuts to high precision
then
they can use they can pass the state of
the algorithm between them
and uh
consequently solve good and hidden hyper
matching itself so suppose alice has her
input of voting like hyper matching
which is just a set of edge labels now
she creates a bunch of these
four vertex gadgets
one for each of the nodes of the of the
cooling hidden hyper matching problem
so when a node is labeled zero um
a b and c d are connected so a b and c d
are always connected but then a node is
labeled zero a d is connected when a
node is labeled one ac is connected so
this is how
the information alice's information is
included in the graph
now at this point alice runs the
algorithm on
this part of the graph compresses this
this compresses her information she
passes the state of the algorithm to bob
and then bob continues by adding more
edges
so
much like alice bob also adds edges
based on his input to boolean hidden
hyper matching
and for each
hyperedge bob is going to create a
corresponding cycle in the graph
um
and he can do it in such a way that um
that the exact structures of the cycle
is dependent on the edge label that he
gets for the corresponding hybrid
so
let's
take a look at an example so
in the case when
bob's edge label is zero or hyper edge
label is zero
he always connects the gadgets d to a so
d1 to a2 d2 to a3 and so on and in this
way
creates a cycle between these gadgets in
this size order t connected component
if
if the hyperedge label is one he does
almost exactly the same thing except for
the last finishing edge of the cycle
which connects between d and b
and as you can see in this example in
the case when the hyper just correctly
labeled so here for example the vertex
labels are 0 1 1 0 and so true parity of
this hyper edge is 0 and indeed it is
labeled with 0
then the the resulting
cycle
is of
even length so there are no odd cycles
this connected component is bipartite
and so the maximum cut is simply
equal to the number of edges
on the other hand um
in this case
when the hyperedge is incorrectly
labeled
and the edge label doesn't correspond to
its true parity
then we create an odd cycle
an odds like of old cycle of approximate
length t
means that the maximum matching maximum
cut size is going to be a factor 1 minus
1 over t smaller
and this is exactly the property that we
were looking for so if there existed an
algorithm that could approximate maximum
cut to either one plus or minus
1 over t
approximation ratio
and then it would consequently also be a
solution to bullying and hyper matching
and therefore it requires n to the one
minus border one over t space
um now an interesting aspect of this is
is that you can see that as the
as the
desired approximation ratio goes down
the lower bound utilizes larger and
larger connected components so here the
size of the connected component in the
lower bound construction scales with t
and this actually doesn't give you a
lower band construction better than root
n for constant size connected components
so
so
a natural question is is this somehow
related to the core difficulty of the
problem
is the problem really only difficult
when or you know only more difficult
than root and space complexity when
there are large components or can we do
something better even on small constant
size components
so this is exactly um the question that
we'll try to
answer
for not just max cut but a lot of other
problems as well with the aid of
noisy boolean
matching
noisy boolean hidden matching
and so
we introduced the communication problem
which we call noisy boolean hidden
matching this is also very similar to
noisy boolean
to boolean hidden matching so alice gets
the vertex labels bob gets a random
matching of linear size
and the edge labels now in the yes case
this is identical to boolean matching
because bob's edge labels will simply be
the true parities but in the no case
in a no case instead of flipping all of
bob's edge labels we only flip a small
random subset of them so instead of
completely reversing bob's edge labels
in the no case
reverse only
we reverse each edge label with
independent probability p for some small
p parameter
and you can notice that this is now a
distributional problem we introduced
some random glass into construction
um
but this doesn't stop it from being
useful as a tool to prove
space complexity lower bounds for graph
streaming problems
and we can analogously define boolean
hidden hyper matching in noise version
as well
so let's see why this is more difficult
to
solve than moving in matching so it's
quite intuitive but it's difficult to
solve right because um
in the no case when bob wants to detect
incorrectly labeled edges it's not
it's not enough to know the parity of a
single edge and verify whether it's
correct or not
even if you verify that the parity of an
edge is correctly labeled it can still
be the node case
and actually even in the no case the
probability that the edge is mislabeled
is very small so
in boolean hidden matching and bullying
and hyper matching
the typical
tight protocol to study is the plaintext
particle which is very simple alice just
selects a size s
subset of his input and sends the
coordinate values to bob
now
bob here is hoping that he's going to
receive an edge which is completely
supported on the known set of vertices
so then buff can bob can just verify
whether the parity label of that edge is
correct or not
and if if he finds an incorrectly
labeled edge then obviously is in no
case
and just like in ordinary bullying in
matching the probability that bob will
indeed have an edge that is supported
in
entirely in the region that is known to
bob due to alice's message is
approximately s squared over n
and this is where the root and
complexity of boiling matching comes
from but unlike ingredient matching now
it's insufficient for bob just find one
edge because an edge only has a p
probability of being incorrect
so actually
um
the probability that the edge that that
bob finds an edge
that is completely supported on the
revealed region
of the of the vertices and is noisy in
the no case is a factor p smaller
and so from this we can deduce that that
our upper bound from the plaintext
particle is root n over p space
for boolean for noisy boolean and
matching and correspondingly for bully
noisy boolean hidden hyper matching
we also get an additional an additional
factor of p to the minus one over t over
ordinary boolean in hyper matching
and in fact it turns out that uh just
like in bullying matching and bullying
hyper matching
um the plaintext protocol turns out to
be optimal
so this is exactly what we proved we
proved that the um communication
complexity of p noisy boolean and
hypermatching
is at least
is exactly
omega root of l over p
and
we use this to enhance a few known
uh streaming lower bound constructions
so for max cut and max matching
we are able to prove that together one
plus p approximation you need omega root
n over p space
so
this is a better than root and lower
bound
even in the case of graphs where the
diameter of each component is bounded by
a constant
and similarly for a maximum a cyclic
graph
um
we get a novel
one plus epsilon approximation lower
bound which is better than
root time
and we also get analogous results for
boolean hidden hyper matching so
again we prove that the plaintext
protocol is optimal in the case of
boolean
and this also helps us generalize uh
some of the applications listed here
so let's see how does the the proof
actually go um
there have been many ways of proving
bullying the matching lower bounds
but one of the main ones
is a through for analysis so the idea
here
is
to look at the posterior on bob's
edge labels conditioned
on the message that alice sent
so conditioned on everything else
uh what do you act what would bob expect
his edge labels to be in the space and
in the no case
and obviously if you can if you manage
to prove a total variation distance um
bound on this quantity
that is much smaller than one then
that's equal that is equivalent to
saying that bob cannot distinguish
between the yes or no cases
and
this is typically done with the aid of
um
of fourier analysis so you can
prove a tvd bound by grouping the l2
squared distance bound
and this is the exact formula that most
papers actually prove that in
expectation over the matching of bob the
posterior of the labels in the s and the
no cases differ in l2 squared
by at most
something that is smaller than a
constant or by at most a very small
constant and therefore
it's impossible to distinguish between
these two cases
um
and actually this seems very feasible
for us too right because we can write up
these two posters very conveniently um
the posterior distribution of the labels
in the yes case is very simple then they
are simple they are just the the true
parity labels
and this is exactly the situation that
is dealt with in the original boolean
hit matching paper
um and it's not much different in a no
case in no case it is again the true
parity labels but uh compounded with
something that is called the noise
operator so this is just the operator
that flips each bit with some small
independent probability p
so and um the
properties of the noise operator and for
a space are
well understood so we can actually
pretty easily write up this formula
however this uh
this
formula this um
inequality
turns out to be simply false in the
interesting domain of s so when s is
greater than the root n bound guaranteed
by bulletin matching
um
that something completely different
happens in the original boolean hidden
matching analysis
the lowest order terms dominate in the
fourier space and you can get this
subconstant bound on the l2 square
distance between the two posteriors
in our case it turns out that higher
order fourier terms were dominant and
this
this bound is simply false so this is
not
a good way of proceeding with the proof
um
so instead we do something completely
different which is an information
theoretical proof
and essentially what we do is we
reformulate noisy bully hit matching
as an amalgam of uh multiple
ordinary boolean hidden magic instances
so it looks something like this
uh suppose alice and bob have several
instances of boolean hidden matching
and what they have to
distinguish between is whether all
instances are in the s case
or a single randomly chosen instance is
in the note case
and one can actually see that if
if it tuned the parameters well and if
we're allowed to set the sizes of these
instances to be random variables
and we
use some additional tricks
then this
this input distribution of this problem
is actually exactly identical to the
input distribution
of noisy boolean and match
so more particularly we have
approximately one over p instances of
ordinary
matching
each instance is of
a random size which is distributed
according to the binary distribution
with parameters np
we also add additional correctly labeled
edges for instance which are useless
to the communication problem but
they help round out the distribution
to be equivalent
to that of noisy bullying and matching
and um finally
alice and bob can randomly permute the
vertices to get the the actual input
distribution of noisy bulletin meshing
so again if we have
approximately one over p of these
randomly sized instances of vhm then one
can see
that
exactly as we desired in the yes case
all edges of the matching are correctly
labeled and in no case
the number of mislabeled edges is
distributed exactly in the same way as
it is distributed in p noisy and
matching so this is an equivalent
communication problem and intuitively um
because there are one over p instances
of bullying than matching and we should
in some sense um
solve all of them um
then hopefully the communication
complexity is additive now this is not
exactly how communication complexity
works but we go through the known method
of
using the additivity of communication
cost instead
um
so the internal communication cost of
sorry the internal communication cost is
defined
as the amount of information that
alice's message reveals about her own
input conditioned on bob's
input and
this is
known to be
at most the communication complexity
which which is of course just the
entropy of ellis's message
um
however
we can show actually that it's not
asymptotically less so in the case of
bullying hidden matching
this is also root n
and due to the additivity of this
quantity we can show that
we have
one over p instances of putting the
matching
each instance is of approximate size p
times n and so they have a
communication cost root of b times n
and this all adds up to be
a lower bound of root of n over p on the
communication complexity of the overall
problem which we have shown is
equivalent to noisy boolean hidden
matching
this is exactly what we wanted to get
so this um
concludes the proof sketch of the main
result
and let's revisit that construction of
maximum cut
so again if we want to prove uh better
than root and lower bound on a small one
perception approximation of maximum cut
we can use these same gadgets so alice
encodes her input
now of boolean of noisy boolean hidden
matching
just as before into these gadgets of on
four nodes
and
but instead of bob having to use uh
large connected components corresponding
to hyperedges
um bob now just has edges
in accordance with noisy boolean and
matching
and
just like before bob can create these
small cycles
that are even length if the
edge is correctly labeled an odd length
if the edge is incorrectly labeled
so here on the left we have an even
length cycle because the edge is
correctly labeled
and on the right we have an odd length
cycle because they are just incorrectly
labeled
and uh so just like before
um if the edge is correctly labeled then
we have a bipartite component and the
maximum cut is the number of edges while
if the edge is incorrectly labeled
then the maximum cut of that component
is a constant
fraction worse
but now because we are dealing not with
the
matching but we put in a bit noisy
matching we have a parameter to tune
that allows us to say that actually not
all even the no case not all of the
components are wrong but maybe only a
small fraction of the components are
wrong and so we can get
a one plus epsilon lower bound for
epsilon
in a wide range epsilon going down as
low as theta one over n
and
in all of these cases we get a lower
bound that is more powerful than root n
in particular it is
root n over epsilon
so in conclusion
we use
in conclusion we have
introduced the communication problem of
p noisy boolean hidden matching and
its analog p noisy bullying and hyper
matching
and we proved that the plaintext
protocol
is tight in terms of communication
complexity on both of them
and we have a few new
simple
graph streaming lower bound results as a
result
of this new tool and
it is our hope that this tool will
produce further
graph streaming lower bounds in the
future
thank you very much